[applause]
>>Teresa Amabile: Thank you so much.
I'm really delighted to be here.
And please don't feel shy.
Come on down in front.
I'd love to have people sitting down close.
I get a lot of energy from being able to talk
to you in this way.
I'm really excited to be here and to be able
to share with you some, what I think, are
some fairly surprising results from our recent
research.
The basic research question is a pretty simple
one.
What makes people happy, motivated, productive,
and creative at work?
Now obviously, this is a pretty important
question because presumably, we all want to
be happy and motivated at work.
And our organizations want us to be creative
and productive.
But the answer to this question really isn't
very simple at all.
For one thing, do these even go together?
Think about the prototypical starving artist.
Do happiness and creativity work in the same
direction or might they work in opposition?
Another question about this.
Should managers care how happy people are
at work?
And also, what influences any of these?
Take creativity for example.
People have been wondering about creativity
at least since the time of Plato.
I, myself, have been studying creativity since
I was about five years old.
Really.
True.
At least, that's the first time I remember
hearing the word "creativity."
I was in kindergarten and I overheard my kindergarten
teacher tell my mother, "I think Teresa shows
a lot of potential for artistic creativity
and I hope that's something she really develops
over the years."
I was ecstatic when I heard this.
I don't think I really knew what creativity
meant, but it sounded good.
I was glad I had it.
And I was looking forward to a lifetime as
a creative artist.
Well, unfortunately, that kindergarten year
was the high point of artistic career.
[laughter]
I really have never done anything with art
after that, and I've often thought about why.
What is it that happened to that promised
artistic creativity?
As I look back on it, I think it might have
had something to do with the kind of day by
day experiences that I had with art in those
years following.
So, kindergarten was in a very progressive,
open-school kind of situation where we had
a lot of free play time and a lot of access
to these wonderful art materials all day.
The following year, my parents enrolled me
in a very strict, traditional, parochial school.
There it is.
St. Joe's Elementary in North Tonawanda, New
York.
Doesn't that look like a lot of fun?
[laughter]
So, at St. Joe's, art, rather than being something
that we did all the time every day, art became
a subject that we had once a week.
And every week, we got the same, pretty bizarre
activity given to us.
We were each given a small reprint of one
the great masterworks in painting and we were
asked to copy it.
So, this is something that we got in Second
Grade--da Vinci's Adoration of the Magi.
And we were told to copy this with absolutely
no skill training and with material that looked
pretty much like this.
[laughter]
This was obviously an exercise in frustration.
And what's more, we were really strictly graded
on these monstrosities we produced.
Mine were true monstrosities.
I couldn't even figure out how to get all
those horses and Saints on the page, let alone
make them look like horses and Saints.
And there was only one time in all those years
in school that I heard the word "creative."
I decided to do something interpretive on
this particular day.
I was doing something abstract during art.
And I heard the nun walking up the aisle.
And then, I noticed that she stopped by my
desk and she was looking down at me.
And then I heard her say, "I think maybe we're
being a little too creative."
[laughter]
I was mortified when she said this.
I was embarrassed.
I was angry.
I looked at her as being a cruel person.
I saw myself as being ridiculous.
And I certainly lost all of my motivation
at that point for doing anything with art.
It was like the last straw in my drive to
do anything with art as a kid.
Now, in an adult at work, I would call that
kind of reaction "poor inner work life."
Let me show you what I mean by inner work
life.
It's the combination of perceptions, emotions,
and motivations that people experience at
they're reacting to and trying to make sense
of the events going on in their work day.
So, inner work life consists of perceptions.
That is, your thoughts, impressions, your
judgments about the place where you work,
your co-workers, your bosses, the work that
you're doing--even yourself as an employee.
So, those are your perceptions.
It's also your motivations, your emotions
and your emotional reactions to what's happening
with what's going on.
And also, you're general mood on a given day.
And it's your motivation for doing the work.
And we found that the most important motivation
for creativity is what we call "intrinsic
motivation."
And that's your passion for doing what you're
doing, your drive to do it because you find
it interesting, exciting, because you're personally
challenged by it.
So this complex of psychological experiences
are inner work life.
Inner work life is called "inner" because
it's mostly hidden.
Let me give you an example of this.
Have you ever been in a business meeting with
higher status people?
When one of those people says something so
outrageous that you're momentarily stunned--I
see some heads nodding--I think many of us
had had that experience.
So, did you say what you were thinking?
If you're like me and most people, you didn't.
Do you let it show on your face?
If you're like me, you did something like
this.
[laughter]
When, in fact, you wanted to react by saying,
"What?
What did you just say?"
So, it's really hidden away.
Co-workers are often not aware on inner work
life and bosses certainly aren't aware of
it, especially if the reaction is negative.
But does it matter?
Does it really matter what people's innermost
thoughts, feelings, are at work?
In short, you bet it does.
It matters a lot.
In fact, inner work life is a central construct
in our research.
It matters a great deal for the work that
people do and it matters for the people doing
that work.
I'm going to illustrate the importance of
inner work life by telling you two contrasting
stories of two companies from our research.
I think of these companies in Dickensonian
terms.
The best of time and the worst of times.
Because the worst company, in terms of employee
engagement and actual success, was like the
evil twin of the best company in our research,
because these two companies were oddly similar
before we started our research.
They were both very well-known companies.
I can't tell you the real names, by the way.
I'm gonna use disguise names because we have
some pretty confidential information on them.
Very well-known companies, very profitable
and known as the innovative leaders in their
industries.
I'm gonna start with the worst.
And it's a company that we call "Karpenter
Corporation."
It's one of the best-known consumer products
brands in the world.
Imagine that you're standing with your co-workers
in the parking lot of the building where you
work.
And you're watching silently as the contents
of that building are being auctioned off--your
computers, CADs, work stations, your desks,
your telephones.
Your chairs are being auctioned off.
You used to be proud to work for this particular
company because it was known for its really
cool innovative products.
But the last few years, innovation began to
fizzle, profitability tanked.
The company was acquired by a smaller rival
and now it's being completely closed down.
And it's breaking your heart.
That's the story of Karpenter Corporation.
And it's the story of the demise of one of
the great consumer products companies of the
20th Century.
Now, let me tell you about the best of times.
A company that we call "O'Reilly Coated Materials."
This company makes coated fabrics for weather-proof
clothing and a wide variety of other products
that are known around the world.
We studied Karpenter and O'Reilly at roughly
the same time period.
And they actually use a lot of the same raw
materials, so the economic conditions for
these two companies were pretty similar.
And yet, Karpenter lies dead and O'Reilly
is still at the top of its industry and is
still known as the innovative leader.
So, what made the difference between these
two companies that looked so similar at one
point?
My research team and I studied these companies
in real time in great detail and I can tell
you what it's not.
It's not any of these things because the two
companies were the same, essentially, on all
of these aspects.
Both public companies.
Both had similar incentive systems.
Because they were so well-known, they were
able to hire the cream of the crop in their
disciplines, highly-skilled employees, and
we had personality profiles on people in these
companies.
And there were no differences.
The personality profiles were in the normal
range.
So, my co-author, Steve Kramer, and I are
both psychologists.
We're not the kind of psychologists who can
cure your neurosis for you, but we are able
to give you a view of what really happens
inside organizations.
And when we took this deep look into these
companies, we realized that what really differentiated
them was inner work life--the inner work life
experiences that their employees were having
day by day.
So it turns out that shortly before we started
our study, a new management team had come
in at Karpenter.
And by what they said and did every day, they
slowly changed the climate at Karpenter.
And they essentially poisoned inner work life.
And this is something that we saw happening
day by day.
So, let me tell you a little something about
how we got our look at inner work life.
It is hidden most of the time.
We decided that the best way to get a window
into what was really going on was to ask people
working on creative projects to send us daily
confidential electronic diaries describing
what had gone on for them in their own work
experience that day and what their inner work
life was like for that day.
So that's what we did--daily, confidential,
electronic diaries.
We studied three industries in this entire
project, a total of seven companies in these
industries, 26 creative project teams.
These are projects that required creativity.
They required innovative solutions in order
to be done successfully.
In these 26 creative project teams, we had
a total of 238 professionals participating
in the research.
Because they participated every day during
the entire course of the project they were
working on, we amassed a total of nearly 12
thousand daily diary reports, which we were
able to analyze.
This was a real treasure trove of data for
us.
We had numerical data.
We actually had day by day scale ratings from
these people of what their inner work life
was like--their perceptions, their emotions,
and their motivation.
We also had numerical data on their performance.
Quite apart from their diaries, we had performance
ratings by co-workers and supervisors throughout
the entire course of the time that we were
studying these people.
And we actually had behavioral measures, too.
I'll tell you a little bit more about that
in just a minute.
To me, the most interesting part of the daily
diaries were the stories that we got about
people's days.
So, at the end of the diary form, we asked
a question: "Briefly describe one event from
today that stands out in your mind from the
work day.
It can be anything at all."
These stories were incredibly rich, often
very detailed accounts of something that had
actually happened that day in these people's
work lives.
Let me give you an example of some of these
diaries that we got.
This first one is from a product manager at
Karpenter Corporation named Sophie.
That's what we call her anyway.
This was one of Sophie's worst days during
the time that we were studying Karpenter Corporation.
She said, "I don't understand why R&D kills
so many of my projects, yet I'm supposedly
measured on new product development.
The VP of R&D killed my new hand-held mixer
three times before it was approved a couple
weeks ago.
Very conflicting goals causing us to start,
stop, restart, etc."
This really was a worst day for Sophie.
Her intrinsic motivation on this day was over
two and a half standard deviations below her
own baseline.
And her affect, her mood for the day, was
one and a half standard deviations below her
own baseline.
Now for contrast, this is a diary from someone
in O'Reilly Corporation, two thousand miles
away, almost at exactly the same point in
time.
This is a team leader named Dave.
"Presented 1.5 hours’ worth of technical
data, market information, process capability
and cost information in the project review.
The review was very well-received.
Much assistance was given and we passed.
We were allowed to go on to the next stage."
Dave's intrinsic motivation on this day was
almost one standard deviation above his average.
And his mood for the day was one and a half
standard deviations above his average.
So, this was a best day for Dave.
And I could give you lots of examples just
like this from O'Reilly Corporation.
I could also give you many examples like Sophie's
from Karpenter Corporation--many days where
that kind of thing happened to a variety of
people.
Now let me tell you something about how we
measured creativity.
We got a quasi-behavioral measure by looking
at what people reported doing that day in
their diary.
Now, we didn't tell them that we were looking
for creativity, that we wanted them to tell
us about their new ideas.
In fact, we didn't even say that we were focusing
on creativity in this study.
But if they happened to report that they came
up with a new idea on a given day, or that
they solved a complex problem, we counted
that as an example of creativity.
So here's an example from a different company.
This is a high-tech firm.
This is from an engineer's diary.
He said, "Working on the details of how the
image will be produced, I really got into
the problem and came up with an elegant method
for dealing with overloaded tasks."
So when we put these creativity data and our
other performance data together with inner
work life data, we made our first discovery.
We call it the "inner work life effect."
And that is that inner work life drives performance.
We found that all three aspects of inner work
life--perceptions, emotions, and motivation--predict
four dimensions of performance.
When people have more positive perceptions
of their organization, their co-workers, their
bosses, the work that they're doing, when
they have more pleasant emotions like feeling
happy, feeling proud, and when they feel stronger
intrinsic motivation, on those days they're
more likely to be creative, productive, committed
to the work, and they're likely to be better
colleagues to the people around them.
So for instance, one study that we did, we
found that when people had more positive emotions
on one day, they were more likely to have
creative ideas that day.
And not only that, they were more likely to
have creative ideas the following day.
Even controlling for that next day's mood.
So we found a carryover effect of positive
emotion on creative thinking.
You could call this inner work life effect,
the Zappos effect.
You're probably familiar with the fact that
Zappos has built this online commerce powerhouse
in part, based on the happiness philosophy
of CEO, Tony Hsieh.
He says, "We believe you can't have happy
customers unless you have happy employees."
And there are a number of people who really
believe that the happiness philosophy is at
least in part responsible for the very high-quality
work you see at Zappos from people, whether
they're working in those call centers, taking
customer orders and dealing with customer
issues, or whether they're working in the
bustling warehouses.
So, this is an anecdote that supports the
inner work life effect we found.
But there was another study that came out
just a few months ago that gives further support
to the inner work life effect.
These researchers used a very different methodology.
They have survey data from over 140 thousand
employees in a variety of companies, business
units, a variety of industries around the
world.
They wanted to see what effect job satisfaction
and people's perceptions of their work environment,
basically, what effect inner work life would
have on bottom line performance of the company.
They found that when a business unit's employees
had higher levels of job satisfaction and
more positive perceptions of their managers,
their co-workers, and their jobs, at one point
in time, that business unit at a later point
in time was more likely to have higher sales
growth, greater profitability, higher levels
of customer loyalty, and greater employee
retention.
So think about it.
Inner work life leads to better bottom line
performance for companies.
So, if inner work life drives performance--and
it does--what drives inner work life?
We decided to take a look at this by isolating
the very best inner work life days from those
12 thousand days of data that we had and understanding
what events actually happened on those days--categorizing
the events, coding them.
And contrasting the events on the best inner
work life days with those on the very worst
inner work life days.
And when we did this, we found that one kind
of event stood out on those best days.
Simply, making progress in meaningful work.
We call this the "progress principle."
The number one driver of inner work life is
progress in meaningful work.
And let me just say something about meaningful
work.
To take a random example, people might find
it motivating to work for a company where
the mission is to organize all of the world's
information and make it universally accessible
and useful.
And even if a company doesn't have such a
lofty goal, as long as people, as individuals,
can see a connection between what they're
doing every day and something that they value,
something that has a sense of purpose for
them, as long as that's true, then making
progress can ignite their inner work lives.
[pause]
Interestingly, this can happen in a variety
of ways.
Let me show you how prominent progress is
on the very best days at work.
When people are feeling happiest, most intrinsically
motivated, and having the most positive perceptions
about their work environment, progress dominates
all other events.
It's by far the most common event on those
best days at work.
Setbacks are the opposite of progress.
And that means being blocked in the work in
some way, having obstacles, feeling that you're
stalled or that you're actually moving backward.
And setbacks were quite minimal on the best
days at work.
The worst days at work are almost exactly
the opposite.
Setbacks dominate on those days.
They dwarf all other events.
And progress is much less common.
So, the progress principle isn't just about
progress.
It's also about setbacks.
As a pair of contrasting events, these two
are the number one differentiators between
best and worst inner work life days.
But the progress principle isn't only about
huge breakthroughs and devastating failures.
One of our most surprising findings is that
even small events can have a huge impact on
inner work life.
Even making small, incremental steps forward
in the work can lead people to feel great.
And we call this "the power of small wins."
I'm gonna give you an example of this from
a diary of an engineer named Tom.
This happened after he had finally defeated
a bug in some software that he was trying
to create.
He said, "I smashed that software bug that's
been frustrating me for almost a calendar
week.
That may not be an event to you, but I live
a very drab life.
So, I'm all hyped.
No one really knows about it.
Three of the team members who had been involved
are out today.
So, I have to sit here rejoicing in my solitary
smugness."
Doesn't Tom sound happy there?
We found that 28 percent of small events can
have a major impact on inner work life.
Twenty-eight percent.
There are a number of interesting things in
this diary of Tom's that I just read.
First of all, Tom tells us about the causal
link.
He doesn't just say that he made progress,
he defeated this bug and he felt good.
He tells us that he felt good because he made
progress.
And we saw this over and over again when people
reported making progress in their work.
They said that they reacted very positively
to it.
The other thing to notice is that this was
just a bug.
In the grand scheme of Tom's work on this
project and the grand scheme of his professional
life, it was no big deal.
But it was.
It was a big deal to him on the day that it
happened.
Unfortunately, it operates in the negative
direction, too.
So, small losses can have a pretty significant
negative impact on inner work life.
And unfortunately, setbacks in the work have
a negative effect that's two to three times
more powerful in the negative direction than
the positive effect of progress on inner work
life.
So there are a couple of implications here.
One is, it's really important to try to minimize
inhibitors to progress, minimize things that
can lead to setbacks in the work.
Even, and maybe especially, minor daily hassles
in getting good work done.
Another implication is that if you have big,
audacious goals for a project, which is great--it's
wonderful to have goals like that--it's really
helpful to chunk those goals down into more
meaningful pieces where people can get a more
frequent sense of achieving small wins.
So, the progress principle is about small
events.
It's about big events.
It's about best days at work, worst days,
and all kinds of days in-between.
In fact, we analyzed all 12 thousand days
that we had data on.
We found significant differences in inner
work life as a function of whether the day
had a progress event, a setback event, or
neither.
And progress is much more likely in some teams
and companies than in others.
I'm going to show you a couple of ratios of
progress to setback events in a couple of
the 26 teams that we studied.
These are really the extremes.
One of these teams was from Karpenter Corporation.
The other one from O'Reilly Coated Materials.
This is the ratio of progress to setbacks
in the diaries from these teams.
Let's see if you can just guess which is Karpenter
team, which is the O'Reilly team.
Yeah, it's not too hard, is it? [chuckles]
The vision team is from O'Reilly Corporation.
They were doing a technically very difficult
project.
They had a lot of setbacks.
But for every setback they reported, they
had five progress events.
The domain team at Karpenter Corporation,
you've gotta pity them.
For every step forward, they make two steps
backward in their work.
Imagine how different it would feel to be
working in these two teams.
So, let's take a step back ourselves right
now and think about the big picture.
Putting together the inner work life effect
with the progress principle.
If inner work life drives performance--and
it does.
That is, inner work life leads people to be
more creative and productive in their work,
to make progress at these creative projects.
And progress leads to better inner work life.
We have a positive feedback loop going on.
And we call it the "progress loop" because
progress is really the greatest leverage point
to get this positive cycle going.
When people are making progress in the work,
that leads to better inner work life, which
in turn will make it more likely that they'll
be creative and productive in their work,
which can keep that positive cycle going unless
something intervenes, something interrupts
the progress, something happens to block the
progress, or something interrupts positive
inner work life and leads it to become negative.
This spiral happens in the negative direction,
too, unfortunately.
So, when people have negative inner work life,
that makes it more difficult for them to make
progress, be creative and productive, which
in turn will lead to deterioration further
in inner work life leading to the kind of
death spiral like we saw going on in the Karpenter
Corporation.
Unless something happens to intervene and
to make progress more likely or to life inner
work life or both.
There was one very bad day for a product designer
at Karpenter Corporation where he seemed to
realize that this spiral was not gonna go
away, that things were not going to be getting
better.
And he was pretty depressed on this day.
And he said, "It's clear to me now that we
are no longer the leader in product innovation.
We are the follower."
So progress is really important.
What can people do?
What can managers do?
What can team leaders do?
What can co-workers do for each other to make
progress more likely?
We identified a couple of different classes
of actions that can keep this progress loop
going.
One we call "catalyst."
These are things that can catalyze progress
in the work directly.
The other is what we call "nourishers."
And these are things that nourish people's
human soul at work.
These are things that directly lift inner
work life.
I'm gonna give you examples of both of these.
First of all, we identified seven primary
catalysts that can jumpstart progress in the
work.
The first of these is having clear and meaningful
goals in the work.
And the second is, even though you have these
clear goals of what you're trying to achieve,
you have some autonomy in deciding how to
achieve those goals.
So, this is the mountain we're going to climb,
but you have the autonomy to use your own
skills, talents, your own expertise in deciding
how to climb that mountain.
The negative of the catalysts we call "inhibitors."
And you can imagine the negative form of these.
Think about Sophie's diary at Karpenter where
she was talking about how conflicting and
unclear the goals were.
Starting the project, now stopping it, now
restarting it again.
She never really knew what she was supposed
to be doing and neither did her team.
At the same time, they had very little autonomy,
very little sense of control over what they
were doing or how they were doing it.
Contrast that with Dave at O'Reilly Coated
Materials, who had a clear sense of where
his project was going in that project review,
yet a sense of autonomy of how to do it.
He got sufficient resources from upper management
to continue to the next stage of the project
and got help.
He said much assistance was given in that
project review--actually got helpful feedback
for going forward in the project.
Now when we say sufficient resources, we don't
mean essentially lavish resources, but just
resources that are sufficient to get the work
done.
Other catalysts.
Learning from problems.
One of the most important ways of catalyzing
progress is to have an atmosphere of psychological
safety where people feel they don't have to
hide errors or mistakes or experiments they
try that don't work out.
But where they know that people are welcome
hearing about these things so that they can
talk about what went wrong, what can we learn
from this, and how can we go forward, rather
than having blame affixed or having people
punished if things don't work out quite right.
This has a huge impact on people's ability
to be creative and productive in their work.
And notice that it's important to learn from
successes as well, not just celebrate it when
something goes well, which is important.
You can do that.
But also to say, "All right, let's debrief.
Why did this work?
And what can we learn from it going forward?"
Having an open idea flow within teams, across
the organization, and even with people outside
the organization.
Now, this doesn't mean that every idea is
going to be accepted, but every idea will
be respected and at least listened to.
And finally, having sufficient time to do
the work, but not too much.
We found that the optimal level of time pressure
for creativity is low to moderate time pressure.
We also found some other, more complicated
effects of time pressure on creativity and
productivity, but we'll save that for the
Q&A.
If you're interested, please ask me about
it.
And now onto the nourishers.
These are things that directly support inner
work life, directly support the people trying
to do the work.
First of all, basic respect and recognition.
A sense that people know you exist and that
your efforts are valued inside the organization.
Encouragement when the work is difficult.
A sense of confidence.
"We know you can do it."
You can imagine the opposite of each of these,
which by the way, we call the opposite of
nourishers, the "toxins" that can poison a
work environment.
Emotional support.
If someone's having difficulty in their professional
life or their personal life, simply having
that acknowledged, having it validated at
work, can make a huge difference in the quality
of their inner work life.
And affiliation and camaraderies.
A sense of bonding with the people you work
with.
A sense of being able to trust each other
and count on each other.
Sometimes it's a matter of having fun with
each other.
And that's opposed to the opposite--the toxins--which
are really negative interpersonal conflict
that can flare up.
And if it goes unchecked, that can poison
inner work life.
So, given these catalysts and these nourishers,
we now have some sense of how to answer that
opening question.
Remember, the question was what makes people
happy, motivated, productive, and creative
at work?
So, what makes people happy and motivated?
What gives them positive inner work life?
Making progress on meaningful work.
And getting nourishers that we just talked
about to sustain their inner work life.
And interestingly, catalysts can also directly
lift inner work life.
You notice that curved arrow at the bottom
of the figure?
When people find out, for example, that they're
getting a new resource, which is one of the
catalysts.
Well, if they find out they're getting a resource
that they really need to make progress in
their work, they feel great.
You feel great, don't you, when you find out
you're getting a resource you really need?
Even before you get it.
Even before it can possibly add to your progress,
you know that you'll be able to make that
progress in the work.
And also, it shows that you are valued by
your organization.
You and your work matter enough to get this
resource.
So, it can have an interesting direct effect
on inner work life to get a catalyst.
And what makes people productive and creative
at work?
What helps them make progress in their work?
First of all, having positive inner work life.
And also, getting a regular supply of the
catalysts day by day.
So progress is key, but is it obvious?
It does seem a little bit obvious sometimes
that well, of course people feel great when
they make progress in their work.
So we wondered, is this really top of mind
for managers?
Do managers know what an incredible motivational
force it is to just get support for making
progress in your work?
So, we recently surveyed nearly 700 managers
from a variety of companies at a variety of
levels around the world.
And we gave them a very simple question.
We said, "Here are five employee motivators.
Rank them in terms of how important you think
they are."
And these are the motivators.
Recognition, incentives, clear goals, progress
in the work, and interpersonal support.
Now, all these are motivators, right?
But we know from our research that making
progress in the work is number one.
So, did these managers rank progress as number
one?
Yeah, not so much.
Number one, recognition, in the view of these
700 managers that we surveyed.
Number two, clear goals.
Number three, incentives.
Number four, interpersonal support.
Yes.
Progress in the work, which we know is number
one as a motivator, came in dead last.
In fact, only five percent of the managers
taking the survey ranked progress number one.
If they were making their choices randomly,
20 percent of them would've chosen progress,
right?
[audience chuckles] So they were actively
saying they didn't think progress was that
important for motivation.
They didn't think it was that important for
them to support progress in the work.
And that's what the question said, actually--supporting
progress in the work.
They didn't think it was that important.
And certainly, in the companies that we studied,
we didn't see a lot of evidence that managers
acted like they thought it was really important
to support daily progress in the work.
In fact, of all seven companies, only one
had managers at all levels and co-workers
across the organization who consistently supported
the progress of the people working in the
creative trenches.
It was O'Reilly Coated Materials, of course.
And by the way, O'Reilly was the only company
to have a true technological breakthrough
in all the months that we were studying them.
And I don't think that's a coincidence.
So what is the implication here?
If you're a team leader, if you're a manager,
what's the implication?
The implication is not that you have to somehow
try to psychologize the people who work with
you and the people who work for you.
You don't have to become an emotional intelligence
genius.
You don't have to pry into people's inner
work lives.
In fact, that would really be a bad idea.
And it doesn't mean that you have to bring
in comedians at lunchtime to cheer people
up.
What it does mean is that you have to support
progress every day.
And the first step is to simply keep yourself
aware of it.
Put in on your mental agenda.
Pay attention to it.
And we think it can help to have a daily progress
checklist.
I don't know if any of you are familiar with
this wonderful book from 2009 called "The
Checklist Manifesto."
Yeah, a few people have read that.
It's by Atul Gawande, who's a Harvard Medical
School surgeon and author on a number of health
topics.
Gawande decided with his research team a few
years ago to see if they could do something
to reduce the incredibly high incidence of
unnecessary complications, and even deaths,
because of surgical accidents.
So they created what they call the "safe surgery
checklist" as a discipline for surgical teams
to follow--something that they actually have
to physically check off the items to make
sure that they've taken care of these things
before and during surgery.
This checklist consists of things that are
blazingly obvious to any surgeon.
Anyone should know to do this, right?
This is good surgical practice.
Things like, everybody on the surgical team
should introduce themselves by name before
they get started, so that if anything bad
starts to happen during the operation, they
can call each other by name.
Something else on the surgery checklist.
Before the surgery starts, we should all say
out loud what side of the body we're going
to be operating on.
Make sure we all agree.
And before we close the incision at the end,
we should make sure that any instruments and
sponges that went into the body have now come
out of the body.
Very basic things.
And yet, following the safe surgery checklist
had an unbelievable impact--a 36 percent reduction
in serious complications and an incredible
47 percent reduction in deaths.
Now management isn't brain surgery, but it
is pretty complicated and there are a lot
of things you have to keep in mind.
That's why we recommend using a daily progress
checklist.
Just spend five minutes at the end of the
day to write down, "OK, what progress did
my team make today?
What might have been holding them back?
What inhibitors might they have been encountering?
Were there any toxins?"
And then, this is the most important piece,
think of one thing that you can do--just one
thing--the following day, even if it's something
small that can enable your people to make
more progress in their work.
And you can do this as a co-worker as well.
In fact, those nourishers and those catalysts
come just as well from co-workers as they
do from team leaders or from higher-level
managers.
In fact, sometimes more effectively.
And keeping a daily checklist or some kind
of a work diary can actually have positive
benefits for your own inner work life and
your own sense of progress.
There's some great psychological research
lately showing that simply writing about something
difficult you're dealing with can help you
feel better about it and can help you plan
to deal with it more effectively.
And noting your progress every day, even if
it's been a frustrating day, noting whatever
progress you did make can rescue your inner
work life at the end of the day and can help
you plan to make better progress the following
day.
So, your big takeaway here is to support progress
every day and support the people trying to
make that progress.
If you can do that inside your organization,
inside your group, inside your own little
team, you will support the inner work lives
of the people around you.
They will feel happier and more motivated
in their work.
They will make more progress in their work.
And that will lead to long-term benefits.
So not only will their personal well-being
be enhanced, but these people will be more
committed and more collegial--
[digital voice]
OK.
I'm not sure what number I'm supposed to press,
but I will finish up.
Let me end with a quote from a programmer
named Tom on an information management team.
This comes from a project that his team was
doing where they were working nearly around
the clock for eight days to solve a very complicated
problem where 145 million dollars were at
stake for the company.
We saw more examples of the progress principle,
more catalysts and nourishers, during those
eight days than we saw in some other teams
during the entire months that we studied them.
The top management in that company cleared
the decks for the team, taking away all other
demands.
They even stopped by to encourage them late
in the evening as they were working by bringing
food and treats.
Other groups inside the company really helped
out doing whatever they could.
The team members rallied around.
One person even postponed her vacation so
she could come in and work with her team.
And of all the catalysts and nourishers, I
think the best came from the team leader herself,
who got in there, rolled up her sleeves, worked
alongside the team every day, helping them
to solve multiple technical problems that
came up and she provided nourishers.
The seventh night, when people were starting
to get really discouraged because they had
one more hurdle to get over, she lifted their
spirits by singing a silly song as midnight
approached.
The result was a superb solution.
Really creative, productive work--
[digital voice]
OK.
I'm assuming that somebody's been dialing
in here and they're trying to get through,
but maybe they can hit their mute button or
something.
So, this is what Tom had to say in his diary
during that golden week.
He said, "The truth is everyone is working
crazy hours, doing impossible tasks, and still
keeping on the cheery side of the street.
God help me.
I do love them so."
So, I've seen it happen.
If you can apply the progress principle every
day, you can make a real difference in your
organization and in the lives of the people
working in it and in your own life.
Thank you very much.
[applause]